[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
bon
où
[Musique]
vous
à l'été 1956 le fln décide de porter la
guerre dans les villes il sait que les
attentats dans alger trouveront une
caisse de résonance de l'opinion
française et internationale
pourtant dans la ville blanche
la première bombe aveugle n'a pas été
posée par le fln le 10 août une
explosion ravage un groupe de maisons
rue de thèbes en pleine casbah
provoquant la mort de dizaines de
personnes
ce sont des européens ultra l'algérie
française qui ont déposé l'engin dans la
capitale algéroise le contre-terrorisme
précède le terrorisme
le chef du fln pour la région d'alger
larbi ben m'hidi un des leader
historique de la révolution et son
adjoint militaire yassef saadi perdre
leurs dernières réticences et décide de
passer à l'action
dans les ruelles étroites de la kasbah
le fln est chez lui yacef saâdi recrute
des jeunes filles qui passent inaperçus
dans les quartiers européens
[Musique]
le 30 septembre 1956 de bombe explose au
milk bar et à la cafétéria de bars du
centre ville fréquenté par la jeunesse
européenne
relève quatre morts et des dizaines de
blessés la psychose de la bombe sale
dans la population alger a peur la
police débordée est incapable de
retrouver les auteurs des attentats est
de combattre le terrorisme urbain
pour parer à cette situation le 7
janvier 1957 robert lacoste ministre de
l'algérie confie au général massu
commandant de la 10e division
parachutiste la totalité des pouvoirs de
police
l'objectif est simple l'anéantissement
des réseaux du fln
les politiques abdiquent devant l'armée
la bataille d'alger commence
alors le pouvoir civil avait donné ordre
au général massu de remettre de l'ordre
autrement dit si on n'avait pas remis de
l'ordre alger il fallait s'en aller
parce que lg était à feu et à sang et la
police ne pouvait rien faire donc les
parachutistes ont reçu l'ordre de
trouver cette rébellion le colonel
bigeard nous a réunis nous arrivions de
chypre nous a réunis en disant voilà la
10e dp prend en charge
le maintien de l'ordre à alger tous les
pouvoirs de police voilà les missions
que nous avons reçue c'est de démanteler
la rébellion et on était il faut bien le
dire en dehors des lois qui avait plus
d'avocats n'y avait plus de justice il y
avait la 10e dp qui rétablisse et
l'ordre dans élevé en liaison avec
massues tous les connaît le parachutiste
on a coupé la villa morceau on a pris
chacun une partie et puis très vite on a
fait des enquêtes policières ce que j'ai
appelé moi un travail de flics que je
n'aimais pas parce que par htc fait pour
se battre en plein jour en pleine nuit
mais pas faire le travail policier c'est
pas son rôle sa
cacher c'était un métier un boulot de
flic
c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai écrit un
jour c'était un boulot de flic mais il
n'y a rien de déshonorant les
parachutistes sont maîtres d'alger
quatre régiments se partagent la ville
qui est quadrillée
[Musique]
on
yacast by bouclé les accès fermés et
contrôlée
et léopard perquisitionnent jour et nuit
arrête des dizaines des centaines de
suspects
[Musique]
mais bon mais existait dans alger nous
le savions il avait 30 56 déjà éclaté
bien souvent donc il fallait trouver
alors les interrogatoires l'urgence est
elle si on ne voulait pas que de
nouvelles bombes saute avant que nous
les ayons trouvé et les hommes qui les
manipulent et en même temps l'urgence
est telle qu'il a fallu accepter m'at-il
semblé en conscience qu'il a fallu
accepter
l'emploi de méthodes d'interrogatoires
musclés
[Musique]
le général massu rédige pour ces trous
une note qui a le mérite de la franchise
la condition sinequanone de notre action
en algérie et que ces méthodes soit
admise en eau âme et conscience comme
nécessaires et moralement valable
dans tous les régiments part à la
torture est pratiquée il faut que le
suspect parle et parle vite arguments
invoqués celui de l'efficacité qui
expose le colonel trinquier spécialiste
de la guerre subversive
supposer qu'une après-midi une de vos
pato est arrêté un poseur de bombe se
pose et alban bébé sur lui une bombe il
avait posé au moins quatre cinq ou six
cette bande démentait nous a permis de
savoir que les bons poser allait sauter
à 6h30 de l'après midi ses trois aires
nous savons que chaque bombe ont fait au
moins 12 morts et une quarantaine de
blessés
le terroriste et là
vous pouvez l'interroger ou non mais
n'empêche qu'à 6h30 vous aurez 40 mans
et linde et environ 200 blessés si vous
interrogez cet individu et à fortes
chances qu'ils vous donnent l'endroit où
il a posé bon ben si vous l'interrogez
peur vous avez couru les honore la
responsabilité des 40 morts et 200
blessés moi personnellement je suis prêt
à l'interroger jusqu'à y répondre à mes
questions
comme trinquier les officiers qui ont
participé à la bataille d'alger avant ce
cas du poseur de bombe qu'il faut faire
parler à tout prix pour sauver des vies
cette urgence justifie à leurs yeux le
recours à la torture
mais les milliers de suspects arrêtés et
interrogés n'étaient pas tous des
poseurs de bombes loin de là les
militaires savent que sur 100 personnes
embarquées dans la kasbah 3 5 ou 10 sont
sympathisants du fln il suffit de les
trouver pour cela tout le monde doit
parler
dans la réalité de la kio mais parra
torture pour arracher des renseignements
qui permettront de remonter des filières
traquer est un adepte de cette pêche au
filet
la casbah d'alger avait 1500 terrus
armes est appuyé par une population de
5000 killer aidés par les renseignements
et ou alors voilà comment nous avons
mené cette bataille d'abord nous avons
voulu connaître leur organisation et
pour ça voilà si comme nous avons fait
vous avez lu mouse et où on vous dit que
les théories sont comme le poisson dans
l'eau bon mais nous avons dit tous les
habitants les connaissent alors nous
avons été une après-midi au début une
trentaine de jeunes gens et nous leur
avons demandés individuel marc quel qui
collecte les fonds chez vous tous nous
l'ont dit on les a relâchés leur matin
nous sommes allés arrêter les
collecteurs de fonds nordea qui vous
porter les fonds ainsi de suite de se
remonter jusqu'au sommet de la pyramide
donc nous avions construit un
organigramme mais il était blanc il
était presque blanc il y avait
simplement quelques noms et à partir de
ces noms il s'agissait pour nous de
raccorder les morceaux de remonter tous
les maillons de la chaîne jusqu'en haut
et là nous avions donc le responsable
d'alger qu'était ben m'hidi ça on le
savait il était tout en haut de
l'organigramme fln la torture massives
organisées revendiqué est justifiée par
la nécessité des résultats
mais les hommes qui ont accepté le
principe où l'on ordonné l'onf et la
mort dans l'âme
bien des officiers pas rater des anciens
de la france libre comme massu et
bigeard
certain 15 ans plus tôt avait été
résistant arrêté ou même déporté
pourtant ces hommes ont accepté des
méthodes révolte et leur conscience
j'ai vu j'ai participé j'ai j'ai
commandé j'ai ordonné puisque je ne vois
pas rejeter les responsabilités sur mes
subordonnés j'ai ordonné parce que ma
mission était et est ainsi fait
je suis catholique pratiquant et rémy
deux ans avant de pouvoir entrer dans
une église il est évident que j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'états d'âme
c'est très difficile sur le plan moral
fallait-il démissionner quitter l'armée
je ne pense pas avoir perdu mon honneur
en algérie disons que j'ai perdu un peu
de mon âme
[Musique]
les parachutistes qu'obtiennent des
résultats et mentale des filières trouve
des caches à côté de l'action des
régiments de la 10e dp une équipe
spéciale mise en place par mathieu est
chargé des basses besognes le commandant
aussaresses et le responsable de cet
escadron de la mort
il vous présente comment votre mission
massue fait ce qu'il vous dit maintenant
comme un l'ordre et de massue vous dis
aussi une façon il faut liquider ses
tripoli 17 organisations et mr lacoste
les ordres du gouvernement
sont de
bloquer l'accès en du fln
par tous les moyens
aidé par tous les moyens
quand on vous dit partout des moyens
vous comprenez ce que ça veut dire et
j'ai compris que ça aurait eu
aujourd'hui moyens y compris la portée
et que c'est ensemble
donc sa torture est beaucoup
séduit partie du ça faisait partie vous
assistiez c'est des interrogatoires non
quelquefois dans certains cas et quand
important et cela vous mener des
interrogatoires non non je n'ai pas moi
même et j'ai mené par
capable
après il est liquide y est quand même ce
que vous aviez interrogé trop durement
non non mon bateau ce pas trop gêner
beaucoup
et c'est que liquider est élevé mais moi
vraiment le monde
le travail de flics départ à porte ses
fruits
le 16 février 1957 le capitaine a l'air
sur la base de renseignements obtenus
par un informateur réussi à arrêter
larbi ben m'hidi
si je reviens à
l'impression qu'il m'a faite à l'époque
où je les capturer et toutes les nuits
nous avons parlé ensemble
j'aurais aimé avoir un patron comme ça
de mon côté j'aurais aimé avoir beaucoup
d'hommes de cette valeur de cette
dimension parce que c'était un c'était
un seigneur benmhidi qu'il était
impressionnant de calme et de conviction
lorsque je discutais avec lui et je lui
disais vous êtes le chef de la rébellion
voilà maintenant entre nos mains
la bataille d'alger est perdu ai-je
extrapoler un peu la guerre d'algérie
vous l'avez perdu maintenant lui qui ne
croyait pas ça et il me rappelait les
champs de la résistance le chant des
partisans
un autre prendra ma place voilà ce qu'il
m'a dit le béjart est venu le voir il a
parlé avec lui il a aussi été très
impressionné par ben m'hidi vous savez
c'est un homme qui était calme serein
je peux même pas dire qu'il était
inquiet il avait déjà compris que la
page était tournée pour lui parce que
que faire de ben m'hidi que faire de ben
m'hidi si vous a donné l'ordre à vous
d'aller chercher ben m'hidi un soir vous
avez reçu un ordre formel
non c'est moi qui ai pensé que
l'imposition de débit j'en était
intenable je ne le cherchez
même si vous avez vous a donné le feu
vert
bon si ce toit
non il n'ya pas d'enfermer les gens
répondre à ces mois démarre à ses
mandats c'est steam c'est pas possible
il n'est pas possible et je n'ai pas eu
le feu vert
vous avez agi là de votre propre
initiative peut même pas que c'était
au-dessus l'acoss qui avait dit faut se
débarrasser de ben m'hidi
je ne dirais pas
voulais pas le dire non vous en pensez
pas - je pense rien du tout et je ne
dirai rien
je l' ai remis à l'état major et à une
équipe qui est venue le chercher et
c'était la nuit et bien que le règlement
s'y opposent je lui avais présenté les
armes parce qu'il faut reconnaître chez
son adversaire la valeur et le courage
et ben m'hidi été pour moi un grand
monsieur d'ailleurs son prénom dans la
résistance était hakim qui veut dire le
pr et quand vous avez été le chercher
que vous avez vu le que allaire qui
faisait rendre les honneurs
club me dit
j'ai pas aimé
pour vous cette année de migrants
on n'est pas les honneurs un ennemi
certains avis
n'ait pas droit aux honneurs de l'armée
française
je pensais devoir tester des airbus
estime bien je vais vous tendez au piège
je tend un piège
je veux pas dire dembélé puisqu'il est
mort mais
j'étais choquée
d'avoir à l'air lui rendre les honneurs
benmhidi
ça m'a fait
de la peine de le perdre parce que je
savais que on ne le reverrait plus je
subodorais après il a disparu il est
parti il est parti il a été remis à la
justice ou dans un camp d'internement et
j'ai appris à travers la presse les
journaux elle et tous les comptes tous
les livres d'histoire que j'ai parcouru
qui s'était suicidé dans sa cellule le 4
mars n'y allez pas cru
mon problème est pas de savoir si je
n'ai cru le problème c'est qu'il est
mort
c'est vous qui l'avez pendu c'est un peu
ça c'est un peu ça ou complètement
ya prescription
justement je verrai pas je verrai pas et
les morts pendus il est mort pendu oui
quand votre présence
je ne vais pas
[Musique]
comme larbi benmhidi ils sont des
milliers les algériens qui disparaissent
walt et jane secrétaire général de la
police refuse que le pouvoir civil
indique totalement devant le pouvoir
militaire il exige que chaque
arrestation sont enregistrés était le
suspect fasse l'objet d'une assignation
à résidence que lui tel gène signe de sa
main
voilà c'est 24 mises
sous mon nom
larmes en quatre groupes
à partir du 4 mai où lorsqu'on mois de
septembre 1956 57 et 1 conduira entre
autres où sont-ils dans les camps a pas
de gaz elle même pas eu à la pause
pourquoi n'y était pas
disparu les oueds la merde et renvoyer
envoyer les crevettes bigeard comme ça
qu'on a prise
mettez les pierres hassine 2 de ciment
dans cet esprit on les algues et enrico
pts à la mer on me parle m sable par la
guerre comme ça c'est pas possible
en attendant de connaître leur sort et
milliers d'algériens arrêtés sont
parqués dans des centres d'hébergement
kate jane nomme ceccaldi raynaud à la
tête du principal centre
tel gène me dit bon le principal va être
situé à beni messous
je vous y envoie
vous représentez le pouvoir civil
il dit c'est moi qui vais prendre les
arrêtés d'assignation à résidence
et
je préfère que vous contrôliez ce qui
s'y passe et soudain
parce que si ce n'était pas un dimanche
arrive
camions remplis de
musulmans que l'on déverse
dans ce centre
et
je vois ce jour là des personnalités
telles que aussaresses lui même qui est
commandant à ce moment là et le colonel
trinquier j'avais 300
300 places de possibles et on y
introduit en quelques heures plus de
mille plus de 1000 personnes puis
quelques jours après j'ai vu des
militaires qui venaient chercher des
gens
5,6 parfois
dizaines et après j'en ai vu qui
rentrait qui avait effectivement des
civils cela j'ai appelé des jeunes
qu'est ce que vous voulez venir moi donc
il est venu
nous avons passé deux heures dans le
centre il a constaté comme moi des
traces de sévices sur un certain nombre
de gens et après la visite nous sommes
monté quelques minutes dans sa voiture à
l'arrière est ce que nous faisons
et m'a dit
ne pouvoir rien
nous luttons contre
d'effort supérieur ne pouvons rien et
pour la morale
démissionnant et c'est ce que nous avons
fait le jour même lui et a démissionné
most
wanted jeunes écrit le 29 mars à robert
lacoste sa lettre de démission qui ne
deviendra effective que six mois plus
tard
j'ai acquis la certitude depuis trois
mois que nous sommes engagés dans
l'anonymat et l'irresponsabilité qui ne
peuvent conduire qu'on crimes de guerre
je ne me permettrais pas une telle
affirmation c'est au cours des visites
récents au centre d'hébergement de polka
zèle et de béni messous jeunes avaient
reconnu sur certains a signé les traces
profondes des sévices ou des tortures
qu'il y à 14 ans je subissais
personnellement dans les caves de la
gestapo à nancy
j'ai des bases et bats la torture ou à
plusieurs frappes alliées chapeau
j'avais comme en humiliant un homme
qu'on le respecte pas qu'on arrive à le
réduire à zéro
plus de concentration d'un show ça me
suffisait
ne pouvait pas supporter que l'eau les
français à juste de même
cette gêne n'est pas le seul à protester
contre les méthodes de l'armée
le général pâris de la bollardière
résistants compagnon de la libération
ancien chef des troupes aéroportées en
indochine comment dans le secteur de
l'atlas blidéen demande à être relevé de
ses fonctions
le retentissement de la démission d'un
officier de la trempe de bollardière la
campagne contre la torture menée par
quelques journaux comme le monde
l'express france observateur le canard
enchaîné mobilise une part de l'opinion
intellectuelle les églises s'émeuvent
le dirigeant socialiste guy mollet ni
tout usage de la torture
pourtant le chef de gouvernement le
ministre résident lacoste le ministre
des armées bourgès maunoury et son
secrétaire d'état à la guerre max
lejeune n'ignore rien de ce qui se passe
dans les locaux des régiments il les
visites approuvent et félicite
avons non seulement été soutenue mais
encouragée je me souviens d'un exemple
précis le général bigeard qui avait un
poste de commandement très organisés
avec des cartes des plans des
organigrammes où on voyait l'évolution
quotidienne de la deûle asphyxie de la
rébellion
nous avons eu la visite de monsieur
bourgès maunoury de monsieur max lejeune
du général salan
de monsieur robert lacoste et de son
chef de cabinet je me souviens à
l'occasion justement de la capture de
ben m'hidi et tous se sont extasiés
devant l'efficacité du travail fourni
par les différents régiments de la 10e
dp ces personnalités politiques ont
trouvé que les résultats étaient
probants et que la méthode était bonne
et nous on nous ont encouragé dans cette
voie
le pouvoir politique accepte découvre ce
que font les militaires
certains ferment les yeux et se bouche
les oreilles robert lacoste lui est
informée à la source
métier tout sur un petit carnet en
quatre exemplaires sur ce n'était pas un
mais des carnets c'était un gros bloc
mis fin au lock oui et
il y avait quatre 4 pages étaient
marqués puis dans un pays où il nous
fait le cadeau parce que passer la
cinquième y allons avec le big de
l'époque
on écrivait si une page sur la première
page c'est marqué des trois autres enfin
je le faisais ça de ma tête j'allais
vous mettre vous notiez tout ce que vous
avez fier dans la nuit oui
vous n'étiez tout vraiment tout vraiment
tout vraiment est jeune on les torture
les érudits taux d'auto enfin bref
et eux
tranquillement rejoignez parce que lui a
vite repéré et on allait voir vinci et
puis je lui disais vraiment changé d'un
point mis en page de la lui donner je
vais expliquer
suite action au courant de tout ce que
nous faisons que ce qu'on faisait et
vous pourrez toujours y compris toujours
et les autres pages et les autres pages
la deuxième est
était pour le serrer cost la troisième
pour le général salan et la quatrième
est resté un archives
lacoste avait aussi tout ce que vous
faisiez absolument il avait droit aussi
au décodage ou totaux de ce que marty
comprenait tous y comprenez vous
et s'il n'avait pas compris il aurait
demandé à massy me comprenez tous
les jours
passer quelques semaines ayant passé
une
audi c'est un premier tir d'honneur
soyez auger j'aime vraiment généralement
et on se prend trop figée
et on trouve
la ghost entrée d'un demi cercle de
fonctionnaires importante
et puis merci se pointe
et lui dit parce que le mouvement
général pour qui la plaie ouverte en
général
les ministres restent au monsieur le
ministre je parvins il a eu un président
une bonne tartine je vous présente le
mâconnais trinquier et le commandant ça
reste et ont joué dans la bataille
d'alger un rôle de premier plan dans la
minute
lacoste vous a dit quelque chose à ce
moment là et il a donné une petite
louche de compliments
ont fait un bon travail je le suivrai
toute ma confiance dans une bonne
dynamique bonne tartine vous avez gardé
un exemplaire
nous sommes un carnet j'ai fait la
connerie n'est pas le garder et
après l'arrestation de larbi benmhidi et
à ses besoins a dit devenu le patron du
fln pour tout alger
continue la bataille traqué isolé il
dispose encore de quelques commando de
choc qui continue à poser des bombes
meurtrières comme au casino de la
corniche le 9 juin l'attentât fait neuf
morts et des dizaines d stroking un
effroyable carnage
la traque de gaza a dit reprend
à la fin de septembre le chef du fln et
arrêter la bataille d'alger est terminée
et parahou gagner
eh bien je pense que nous avons été très
efficaces
mais
ce n'est pas le genre d'opération le
genre de mission que je referai avec
plaisir
c'était une mission très difficile qui
est tout à fait hors norme par rapport à
l'éthique de l'officier occidental et
chrétiens de surcroît mais nous étions
pris par la mission donc nous avons
essayé de la remplir le plus humainement
possible même si ce mot paraît un petit
peu surprenant dans la bouche d'un
officier parachutiste qui a participé à
la bataille d'alger
les obliger pas efficace
on trouve et on obtient l'un torturés
humiliés renseignements et si l'on y
regarde de plus loin on s'aime
d'une haine qui au nom de l'efficacité
parental de tous c'est tout le contraire
et
la torture appliquée au travers de
l'histoire
conduit à
part à la révolte de ce même que nous
prêtions torture et des autres
jerry c'est l'échec gagnent la bataille
d'alger envers l'algérie parce qu'elle
était déjà bien ta torture le fait que
que salir un peu plus l'image qu'ils
auraient pu regarder
la participation au défilé du 14 juillet
d' unité de parachutistes que nous
voyons ici s'embarquer à alger a fait de
la fête nationale en hommage aux
combattants d'algérie
rayonnante aux cérémonies des champs
elysées le président bourgès maunoury a
remis dans la cour d'honneur des
invalides les insignes de grand officier
de la légion d'honneur au général massu
chef des parents
le 14 juillet 1957 les hommes de massue
défilé sur les champs-elysées profitant
de la démission des politiques l'armée a
pris le pouvoir à alger elle ne le
lâchera plus ce sont les mêmes hommes
qui quelques mois plus tard au moment du
13-mai dicteront leurs volontés à paris
[Musique]
avec l'appui de ma suis de salan de
gaulle revient au pouvoir les français
d'algérie et les cadres de l'armée se
félicite le malentendu commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
oui mostaganem
[Musique]
ebp l'algérie française
vive la république il avoué
[Musique]
de gaulle nomme un nouveau commandant en
chef à la place de salles en le général
challe s'inspirant des théoriciens de la
guerre contre révolutionnaire ceux qui
ont mené la bataille d'alger préconise
le contrôle systématique de la
population pour isoler le fln évacuées
des régions entières deviennent des
zones interdites où les soldats français
n'a tiré sans sommation sur tout ce qui
bouge les habitants chassés de leurs
villages sont rassemblés dans des camps
de regroupement où s'entassent bientôt
un million et demi de personnes surtout
des femmes des enfants et des vieux qui
survivent dans des conditions précaires
et maladies le manque de nourriture
entraîne une forte mortalité
[Musique]
grande partie des opérations se
déroulent dans des zones interdites car
le quadrille achats l'avait conduit à a
baptisé des territoires entiers zone
interdite d'où il devait y avoir
personne tout mouvement à l'intérieur de
cette zone étaient soit des militaires
français soit des fellaghas mais je sais
comment une zone devient interdite parce
que je les ai vécus et c'est tout
simplement il ya eu deux des convois
tuchan passé il ya eu une ou deux
attaques de convois re quelques morts et
puis l'état major dessine un trait cette
somme elle est interdite vous tirer sur
tout le monde mais les gens qui sont là
bas est sympa c'est pas une zone
interdite pour les habitats ils ont leur
chef leur show et puis comprennent que
c'est que c'est une zone mortelle et
bien c contient des militaires qui
passent et plus le gagner en train de
labourer son champ et le mitraillent
[Musique]
à partir de 1959 le général challe
montrent de grandes opérations qui
visent à démanteler complètement
l'organisation du fln et à détruire les
katiba de la lnd milliers d'hommes
surtout des parachutistes format
gigantesque rouleau compresseur qui
balaie l'algérie d'ouest en est
[Musique]
on
les combattants de la ln qui réussissent
à échapper aux taux n'aille se réfugient
dans des endroits escarpés où il faut
les poursuivre c'est le rôle d' unité
spéciale les commandos de chasse composé
de quelques dizaines d'hommes lui plus
souvent des harkis qui connaissent bien
le terrain
c'était des teams gonfler un parce que
ils allaient dans en pleine zone
quelquefois occupée par les
parle par la ln il se faisait une entrée
dans les mechtas il se faisait passer
pour des partisans de la ln il avait des
laissez passer qui avait été pris lors
d'opérations à la ln il est présenté aux
gens ils se présentaient comme des comme
des faits loose comme le commando
georges
[Musique]
le commando georges et le plus célèbre
des commandos de chasse formé par
d'anciens maquisards effet l'aisne
souvent torturé puis retourner il en est
d'autres peu regardant sur les méthodes
dans la réputation et frais dans les
douars
[Musique]
ce lieutenant il m'a raconté des choses
incroyables sur la manière d'un film
dont il faisait disparaître les
individus suspecte il m'a raconté
comment il faisait ça je vous donne ma
parole que c'est seulement exactes sont
ces propos textuel il m'a dit voilà il
arrive que
on sait par la tête du corps ont des
gens que l'on a trucidé on fait bouillir
la tête dans de l'acide sulfurique
les restes sont jetés dans le jardin et
le corps est embarqué dans un dans un 4
4 d'élire un dodge et là à des endroits
où on sait que le le le sable leur
couvrira bien on dépose le corps et on
en parlera plus jamais c'est ainsi que
moi j'ai su qu'il y avait des gens qui
avaient disparu de biskra
[Musique]
quand ils sont arrivés la première fois
j'ai fait demi-tour vite fait je suis
rentré dans le gourbi qui nous servait
de l'infirmerie à la salle je suis
ressorti à une amie très chère eiffel
qui arrive là c'est pas possible je les
ai vus ensuite s'intéresse à lui faire
quoi alors tu es d'abord première chose
il faut aller crescendo d'abord il
rentre dans le village il rassemble les
hommes mais à part avant de les
rassembler ils apprennent à part a le
couteau sous la gorge tu ne donnes tes
sous
déjà hippiques
ensuite ils viennent à l'as djerba ils
sont réunis à la jam à la jemaah là jean
macé le lieu c'est notre mairie c'est le
lieu panneaux de meriem est le lieu de
rassemblement 1 le lieu de rassemblement
bon et bien là
les hommes sont au programme a rassemblé
là celui qui marche pas si vite on tue
sans autre forme de procès on tabasse
tout le monde il n'y a pas plus de deux
commandes de suspect que autres et où
les tabasse pas n'importe comment avec
une canne et ça c'est pire que la gégène
et pire que tout le reste vous avez une
canne ou une what you re cité des cannes
et vous tapez mais tout doucement s'agit
pas d'aller taper un grand coup vous
allez il va tomber dans les pommes c'est
si on tape tout doucement à gc soigner
mais derrière ces gens là la furie il
fallait voir dans quel état c'était il
ya un dos le dos des pulls et noir il
est donc il parle oui parle pas s'ils
parlent pas ils tuent et s'il parle
qu'est ce qu'il va dire i c'est pas
ça c'était vraiment des tortionnaires ce
commando de chasse étaient les ss en
algérie rien de plus
partout où ils sont passés ils n'ont
fait que deux alors les viols mais n'ont
jamais violé une gamine de 19 ans de 10
ans de 11 ans de 12 ans c'était ça on
voyait les pères venir nous voir après
ils ont cassé ma fille mais c'était 7 et
c'était impensable jamais je n'ai vu
torturé comme avec cela pss voilà le nom
du commando de chasse p16 50% c'était
des feux lavea qui avaient été arrêtés
qu'ils avaient été torturés qui avaient
vendu leurs frères
ça fait la ronde de l'armée française ce
moment de chasse
[Musique]
dans cette guerre spéciale où la
contre-guérilla utilise les méthodes de
la guérilla et renseignements reste
primordiale désormais la recherche de
l'information est organisé méthodique un
organisme unique le dup dispositif
opérationnel de protection est chargée
des interrogatoires le travail est
confiée à des spécialistes militaires ou
policiers véritable professionnel de la
torture chaque secteur à son dope lieux
fermés mieux se crée une vraie usine à
torture et
on les donne à l'officier de
renseignement qui lui et essaye de les
faire parler s'ils ne parlent pas je
parle de mon secteur il partait au top à
tizi ouzou où la torture là c'était fini
le bar le royer plus bien donc chaque
type d'auto job c'était le le
détachement opérationnel de protection
si c'est pas ça du tout c'était le
centre de torture tout simplement un il
y avait les bi fameuse villa apprend
dans la bataille d'alger bain en grande
kabylie c'était le drop à tizi ouzou et
viser tout un au début avec une
quinzaine de dope et puis après on en a
mis un peu dans tout le principe
recherchait c'était d'avoir des docks
dans tous les secteurs un injecteur
c'était un arrondissement en gros il
décidé que quand il y avait un
prisonnier qui il était interrogé par
une
forme de centralisation
de l'interrogatoire les dogues s'étaient
des organismes civilo militaire il y
avait des militaires mais il y avait des
gendarmes il y avait des policiers qui
étaient tout
claude rang fin à 18 ans en 1959
lorsqu'il s'engage dans l'armée
il se dit gaulliste est parti en algérie
française il se retrouva maison blanche
près d'alger dans une brigade très
spécial
et puis le travail a commencé quoi
c'était pas trop ils contrôlent
embuscade et puis bon bain lorsqu'il y
avait des prisonniers bon bah
on essayait d'en tirer le maximum pour
avoir des renseignements classés ou
c'est vous qui peuvent y est c'est fait
et on vous les a portés ou donneront
demain on était à cantonnement n'était
pas beaucoup on était une trentaine de
militaires ces officiers compris et
vous savez bon faisait pas c'était pas
s'était dit ce n'était pas des
interrogatoires com
si si les gens voulaient coopérer ça
allait bien mais quelquefois il y avait
il ya eu quelques petits débordements
mais enfin disons que c'était quand même
pas la plaisanterie j'ai durement mais
vous les tortures et voilà mais je pense
que bon comme tout interrogatoire quand
on veut arriver à quelque chose mais
entre la le mot torture fait quelquefois
très déplacé pour vous ça commence sous
la torture ben la torture moi je pense
que c'est que quand on commence
nous ce qu'on essayait plutôt de faire
c'était plutôt
psychologique au point de départ on
essayé de leur expliquer bon
ici on l'a essayé de leur faire peur
déjà que si jamais il parlait pas bon
bain qui risquait ceci qu'ils risquaient
cela et 6,6 que si coopérerait pas avec
nous eh bien on essayait bas quelquefois
bon bah ça ça prend des tournures c'est
ce qu'on appellera des interrogatoires
musclés quoi mais la torture à vous
utilisiez l'électricité la gégène tout
ça oui oui oui vraiment encourageant
ongles dans cet ordre aux stars et moi
j'y suis passé à la gégène
quelquefois pour s'amuser on se branche
s est pas si terrible que ça avançait de
la fédé téléphone de campagne vous
imaginez combien de temps comment vous y
passiez combien de temps pour moi oui je
sais quand vous vous amusiez ont fait de
bons branche un muret de minutes ouais
ça a duré quelques minutes quand vous
prenez des prisonniers
vous oui oui quelques fois beaucoup il
c'est vrai mais vous vous participiez
directement aux interrogatoires vous
surveillez vous or nous vous y alliez
jugé suis j'ai participé je participer
[Musique]
vous savez la torture enfin je vous ai
bien dit le mot torture me dérange un
petit peu disons les interrog
l'interrogatoire disant qu' il faut le
pratiquer il faut pas qu'il est sans
haine
sont perversité
faut pas que ça ne faut pas que ça soit
un jeu ni à plaisir c'est simplement le
pot pour arriver à un résultat qui va
permettre de sauver des gens vendent eux
c'est tout pendant les interrogatoires
vaut garder la tête froide vous étiez
pas pris dans une espèce d'ambiance un
peu
j'arrive à garder non non non non non
non moi je ne me je sais que moi
personnellement je ne me suis jamais
me suis jamais excité n'est rien du tout
bon donc j'avais du respect faut pas
croire bon et puis une fois que c'était
fini une fois de bon ben il était il
était déclaré de toute façon
officiellement on en a eues on a eu des
prisonniers où ces corps le matin pour
ce n'est arrivé
d'être responsables des cellules
galles matin
on leur faisait faire la culture
physique parce que bon bah il était
quand même enfermés dans des cellules
dont qu'on les sorte est vers la culture
physique on faisait un peu faire des
mouvements puis nous aussi comme ça ça
nous fait de faire des mouvements en
europe isabelle café il passer à la
douche puis après on avait un petit
jardin on avait un jardin dans la
brigade bon il y en a qui bon
qui faisaient le jardin donc qu'il avait
les tenues d'autres une bombe mais enfin
disons qu'il n'y avait pas de bombe à
c'était fini il était prisonnier était
prisonnier on les remettait à la justice
et puis et puis voilà quoi finalement
vous alliez du respect pour les gars
vous parce qu'à la gégène bah oui bon
bien sûr qu'on a du respect quand même
bon je pense que je ne sais pas au
moment où je sais pas si j'avais été
algérien je ne sais pas ce qui bon moi
j'ai connu des dés
des gars de la ln qui avait combattu en
39-40 chez nous pour la france qui avait
combattu pour la france en indochine qui
se retrouvaient et demi après contre les
françaises
finalement vous y faisiez un travail de
professionnel presque oui
certains manière valait mieux tomber
entre vos pâtes contre pas de quelqu'un
qui était pas que quelqu'un qui n'a
aucune formation et qui risquait de
faire des bêtises c'est fort possible
[Musique]
ge est resté combien de temps la maison
blanche à faire ce travail
j'y suis restée jusque le 11 décembre
1961 jour de la saint daniel suspense et
vous aviez commencé et j'ai commencé un
mois 2 en 60 au mois de
octobre 60 un peu plus d'un an après un
peu plus d'un an
alain teissonnière est cantonné dans une
ferme près d'oran qui se transforme peu
à peu en centre de torture
après il ya eu de plus en plus de
prisonniers dont qu'on pouvait pas les
attacher un à un tous les soirs où toute
la journée donc on a transformé le
hangar en prison on a mis des barbelés
devant le la partie qui était ouverte on
l'a laissé un petit passage on a attaché
un chien d'armé avec une grande chaîne
pour qu'ils puissent sauter surtout
fuyards et on changeait le chien tous
les deux jours pour qu'elle obtienne
s'habitue pas à ce que la situation et
on a placé une sentinelle devant de la
prison sont ils bien sûr qu'il
souhaitait renouveler toutes les deux
heures ces gens-là policiers capitaine
et autres
tortures est cette fois ci plus dans la
prison est le même mais dans d'autres
salles à l'intérieur de la ferme alors
on entendait les cris on entendait les
coups et on voyait les dégâts sur les
prisonniers par exemple y en avait un
qui avait été
arrosé d'essence sur ses cheveux on
avait mis le feu donc ils avaient ils
étaient tous deux roulaient sur la tête
un autre avec les doigts écrasés pouvais
plus servir de ses mains un autre on
l'avait vu
attachez ligoté dans un réseau de
barbelés au soleil toute la journée et
lorsqu'on était dans la cour ou de garde
sur la terrasse on pouvait observer le
supplice de la baignoire qui était
pratiqué dans l'abreuvoir remplie de
doutes lessive et donc on plongeait le
prisonnier à nu dans l'eau et les
tortionnaires le sortait de temps en
temps il jeté par terre le type essayé
de souffler un peu et leur plongée
pendant plusieurs fois et après ils leur
ont marqué du côté du des salles de
torture
je me souviens une fois où j'étais de
garde aux prisonniers comme on disait
j'attendais la fin de la faction et
j'entends crier sentinelle c'est je me
retourne et je vois arriver vers moi un
prisonnier manifestement mal traitée en
mai mal en point il avait du mal à
marcher et derrière lui sur le pas de la
porte qui avait un si lille un policier
le fouet à la main tout fier que comme
s'ils avaient fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et tout de suite mais
venu à l'esprit gestapo
d'après ce que vous voyez les torturer
étaient fréquentes cesser tous les jours
pratiquement alors on a eu en moyenne
une quarantaine de prisonniers pendant 8
à 10 mois et au plus fort y en avait une
soixantaine on avait calculé qu'il y
avait autant de prisonniers quatre
soldats dans la ferme c'est à se
renouveler en permanence ça se
renouveler en permanence cette ferme qui
était sans de torture ça
correspondait à quoi territorialement là
je ne sais pas justement c'était un peu
la question que je me suis posée
lorsqu'on a parlé si souvent de
des tortures par les parades la bataille
d'alger en 57 et que on parlait très peu
d autres centres de torture à part la
ferme ameziane main je me demandais mais
le centre où j'étais qu'est-ce que
c'était vis-à-vis des différents centres
de torture pour s'appeler cet endroit où
vous avez été affecté à constantine la
ferme à meziane et c'était une ferme qui
avait été réquisitionné par l'armée et
toutes les arrestations toutes les
interrogations se faisait dans cette
ferme tous les suspects que nous on
arrêtait et tous les suspects la plupart
des suspects arrêtés dans le
constantinois
arriver là ah oui oui on en avait
beaucoup beaucoup on avait au moins
cette époque là je pense qu'on avait au
moins deux cents 200 go quand même océan
enfermé en permanence en permanence il
en arrivait tous les jours on arrivait
tous les jours une en partie en arriver
[Musique]
opinion tout autour il y avait des
lotissements c'était les étables les
dans les étapes qui étaient détenus les
dents woods était couché sur de la
paille s'était couché sur de la paille
et a par la suite après ils ont fait
faire quelques cellules pour casser les
qu'ils ont monté en parpaings et puis
avec des portes en fer
est dedans bien il y avait mettez des
gants qu'il fallait vraiment isolé
[Musique]
qui menaient les interrogatoires
et comment des inspecteurs en civil
principalement et pas de militaires à
moi j'en ai pas vus et vous vous
assistiez aux interrogatoires oui j'en
ai vu moi j'en ai vu de plusieurs façons
j'en ai vu aussi bien comme on dit là
bas je gêne qu'ils appelaient ça sur un
lit de camp d'or il attachait sur lycans
et puis il mouillait et pierrick âgées
jeunes et j'ai vu aussi
assis sur une chaise et avec de l'eau et
de la lessive forme et avec un manteau
noir dans la bouche et puis moi ça y est
les faire parler comme ça et puis après
il recrache assez tôt les conseils
continus est un baiser préparer nos
essais durer longtemps
oui c'est dû rester longtemps et ce type
de torture électricité l'os a été
employée fréquemment bas nous c'était
dur c'était toute l'énigme s'étaient
toutes les nuits
les séances de jeunes pouvaient durer
longtemps oui oui et puis après ben
celui-là quand il les fit parler ils
forcent un peu sur la manivelle et puis
c'est réglé
c'est à dire il pousse jusqu'au moment
où le coeur et lâche
en quatre ans des dizaines de milliers
d'algériens sont passés par la ferme à
meziane des milliers ont été torturés en
un lieu sûr nommé l'abattoir plus de
mille détenus y laissèrent leur vie
à la ferme au je pense que j'ai dû
rester pendant un an et demi à peu près
j'ai passé presque tout mon temps
[Musique]
en juin 1961 henri pouillot arrive à
alger il n'a aucune conscience ni
appartenance politique il est affecté à
la ville a saisi ni pour effectuer du
travail de secrétariat
commun du jour vous avez découvert que
finalement ce cette ville a été un
centre de torture je le découvert
n'avait de trois premiers jours quoi les
les séances et plusieurs les plus
violentes se passe en général dans le
sous-sol de la wilaya va livrer des
lieux qui est aménagé où c'est aussi
aménager cette façon très sommaire il y
avait deux trois chaises
de trois tables
essentiellement métalliques des tables
de l'armée de l'époque
cavaloc est nettement plus pratique
parce que le métal compte bien
l'électricité donc il suffisait de
brancher souvent une une électrode sur
la table et l'autre sur la personne qui
permettait d'avoir les contacts entre le
corps et ses terrains et vous
personnellement vous avez assisté à ces
séances de torture est descendu dans la
droite avait joué parce que très souvent
c'était souvent d'enquêté chargée de
décider de prendre les notes et
importante qu'il fallait une qu'il
fallait conserver quoi et puis j'avoue
que
je me sentais moins malade ou si josi
à être avec un stylo au crayon que
que d'avoir
à exercer des brutalités quoi
bien sûr mais intellectuellement vous
fait une différence finalement le fait
de deux parcs de noter une fête de
tourner le magnéto
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir participé les interrogatoires
jorisch
je me sens moralement totalement
complice est totalement même solidaires
de ces actes de torture parce que j'ai
pas plus j'ai pas sujet pas je peux
juste pas comment le dire
faire autrement que de que d'être partie
intégrante de ces unités de torture mais
en plus ce qu'ils étaient en plus
difficile c'est que la plupart de ces
interrogatoires de de ce type
d'altération très très musclé il se
passait dans ce sous sol où il y avait
toutes les
et toutes les cellules qui était à côté
où tous les autres prisonniers y est
vous avez des fois jusqu'à une vingtaine
de prisonniers étaient enfermés dans les
lacets petites cellules à côté quoi donc
la plupart des détenus
pouvaient voir en partie souvent
d'ailleurs ce qui se passait parce que
les portes de ces cellules étaient en
général d y avait souvent défendre c'est
dans ces cellules d'un support de
cellules et en plus il entendait tout ce
qui se passait par pratiquement alors il
y avait des combinaisons très divers sur
ces problèmes là pour essayer de faire
parler aussi bien faire parler des gens
devant l'autre en faisant si les
torturaient repères devant le fils soul
inverse où un enfant il ya même eu des
enfants ces jeunes qu'on eut des
tortures qui ont pas été très très
violentes mais quand même devant les
parents quoi on me dit tiens c'est jeune
c'est quel âge
à partir de 12 ans quoi
[Musique]
et puis tous les viols aux hommes et aux
femmes les hommes et à geler sa part
débattons par les canaux fusil de
deux pistolets autre chose puis viennent
les femmes
se peut violer aussi bien
géré par des objets divers que par
là que par les sexes des soldats quoi
et en plus il est arrivé très souvent
que des femmes sont raflés
simplement pour pour être violée dans
cette période pourrait servir pour le
sauna qui étaient là quoi
pour avoir une idée de l'étendue de la
pratique fou dans le temps où vous vous
étiez là dans cette villa vous avez
assisté à combien de ces séances et ce
coût est chiffré ce que ça représentait
comcom que j'entends tueur et
je serais tenté de dire qu'il y avait
bien eu en moyenne une dizaine à une
quinzaine de personnes qui étaient très
sérieusement torturé par jour alors si
vous faites le compte sur sur 30 jours
parce que ya pas de samedi et dimanche
il n'y a pas de jours fériés dans ce
type d'activité s'est fait dans les
trois 3 400 par par mois sur sur 400 se
fait bien contre quatre et cinq mille
personnes côté torturé dans la mise à
pendant la période où j'étais
parce que quand même c'est
n'importe quoi
la torture
aucun acte de torture ne s'est produit à
ma connaissance ni à lavau depuis
l'avenue âgées du général l'autre il ne
doit plus s'en produit désormais
dès son retour au pouvoir général de
gaulle interdit le recours à la torture
lors de cette tournée des popotes il
répète que le téléphone doit servir pour
parler non pour faire parler en vain sur
le terrain les militaires font la sourde
oreille en visite au pc de bigeard de
gaulle lui demande que cesse la torture
plus tard bigeard confie à ses officiers
de gaulle a dit plus de torture alors
messieurs je vous dis plus de torture
les tortures et quand même
et
la danse une autre fille nasa
14 quelle présence quelle présidence il
y à vraiment pas tomber en france le
camp militaire c'est quoi c'est un
rectangle
de 50 mètres sur 50 m dans lequel on vit
ici à 60 personnes 24 heures sur 24 ce
qui fait qu'il ya une exaspération
imaginez cette énergie qui peut se
dégager de ces jeunes qui ont 20 ans qui
sont peintes forme en pleine santé et
qu'ils sont sans occupation autre que de
boire des canettes de bière parce qu'il
fait chaud ou de voir ses allées et
venues de prisonniers ces
interrogatoires donc il ya une décharge
électrique permanente et puis il peut y
avoir aussi des sentiments de violence
contenue qui se décharge on se trouve
incorporé dans un groupe
de 10 entre 10 et 25 soldats ça dépend
des périodes
ce groupe il est constitué il ya des
règles de fonctionnement
discipline mais quand même mairie terre
ou
des habitudes sont prises où chacun un
peu une fonction a une réputation
là
[Musique]
comportement si vous ne suivez pas le
comportement du groupe vous devenez la
marginale vous devenez un rebelle
il ya beaucoup de risque évidemment il
faut avoir la force de le faire bon et
puis il ya toujours ce fameux argument
si tu le fais pas tu es un dégonflé bon
chrétien l'instituteur jean yves temple
ont effectué son service militaire en
grande kabylie
un jour brutalement il découvre la
réalité odieuse de la guerre ils
découvrent en même temps que le
spectacle du mal peut captiver
donc dans une petite grange je me
souviens très bien de l'endroit une
grange
qui devait servir bon il y avait encore
de la paille ou du foin chez pas trop
bon et dans cette branche bon pour la
décrire c'est intéressant de teen usa
oui bon
je me souviens qu'on avait aménagé une
mezzanine sur la gauche
dans laquelle elle dormait au jeu dirait
bien qu'il y avait au moins six
militaires 6 appelez-la qui dort mais
bon on y accéder par une petite échelle
de manière bon et l'intérieur d'un set
de cette petite pièce là étaient
tapissés de photos pornographiques
moi qui venais si vous voulez du ça
aussi moi j'avais jamais vu un bouquin
un bouquin porno j'avais jamais bon je
découvrais bon qu'un
hacker bon on pouvait alors il y avait
une espèce de fascination évidemment
bon malsaine bon et dans cette grange
bombe chez
j'ai vu
à mener à un homme un suspect comme on
disait à l'époque bon
alors pourquoi j'étais là à ce moment là
pourquoi j'étais là je ne dormais pas
dans la mezzanine pourquoi je me suis
trouvé là ce moment là je suis incapable
de le dire mon âge j'étais et
je n'assistais a finalement à quelque
chose de terrible mais kim apparaît
maintenant comme un rituel comme quelque
chose qui dont on connaissait le
l'introduction le développement la
conclusion ça se dérouler mais on avait
l'impression qu'on savait comment s'y
prendre et que ce n'était pas la
première fois
alors cet homme bon ggd
il est haï très précis qui me reste est
qui et qui sont toujours
terribles un cessez de
cet homme a été attaché bon il y avait
une est une petite poule i dans cette
grange ou qu'ils devaient servir à
monter les bottes les bottes de paille
vont sait et on l'a attaché par les
mains vont en eau
et
il y avait le fameux gégène c'était pas
le téléphone de campagne c'était un
modèle beaucoup plus perfectionnés enfin
modèle qui se dont les choix qui ont les
pieds se repliaient puis avait une
petite salle bon face à devait être un
modèle
plus plus plus puissant plus
perfectionnés si je puis dire mon
est alors bon cet homme
a commencé à lui poser des questions je
me souviens plus des questions mais
c'était toujours les mêmes probablement
pour avoir dû des renseignements savoir
si les fellaghas était passé chez lui
s'il les avait approvisionner ci s'ils
paient les s'ils paient les fellaghas
évidemment bon bah c'est camille bailly
là il a parlé dans cette eau mena
cet honneur elle n'a absolument rien dit
alors les électrodes bon c'est un
promener sur tout le corps bon je me
souviens même de 7
sur la trace qu'on avait
mis sous lui un traitant de faire un
tréteau métalliques
sur lequel
non le montech la pluie
quand on a vu que les électrodes mais ça
ça a duré longtemps ne n'obtenez pas de
résultats on l'a lâché les jambes
écartées sûre sur le très tôt de faire
bon
puis alors ce l'horreur l'horreur pour
moi cela
c'était après quand cet homme bon qui
qui qui geignent et qui
d'entendre je crois que c'est un
sous-officier
un sergent-chef qui commande et tout ça
veut dire
aller chercher son enfant allait y aller
chercher son fils au fait je me souviens
très bien c'est de cette parole
j'ai vu arriver bon gamin de
moi je dirais 13 ans 12-13 ans bon et le
le gamin
entre les mains duquel on a mis on a mis
une électrode et on l'a on l'a poussé à
l'unama
torturé son père comme
un moment émouvant table pour moi et
parce que ce qui me
maintenant quand je parle 700 banquiers
que je peux pas banaliser évidemment bon
jeu je suis très mal à l'aise très mal à
l'aise moi même parce que
par ce que j'ai vu bon j'ai vu cela et
je n'ai rien dit mais il ya autre chose
encore de plus
le plus dur à dire peut-être mais c'est
que je n'étais pas le seul d'ailleurs
parce que les militaires sur la
mezzanine je me souviens qu'il y en
avait quelques-uns qui était
les jambes dans le vide là et qui qui
était comme comme au balcon à qui
existait un peu à ça avant et j'avoue
que ce que
ce que j'ai ressenti le seuil est une
espèce de une fascination véritable je
me suis rendu compte que
on pouvait
ressentir en soi une certaine forme de
jubilation a assisté à des scènes aussi
extrêmes bon et
je vous jure maintenant je rattache à
immédiatement à ses lacets photos pornos
que je voyais dans le dans la mezzanine
en me disant mais au fond
rien il ya un rapport évident entre les
deux c'est à dire on a instrumentalisé
le corps 1 d'un côté c'est pour le
plaisir de l'autre côté c'est c'est
peut-être aussi une forme de plaisir à
faire d'un corps ce que l'on a envie de
faire mais avec ses envies les plus les
plus malsaines et les plus profondes
vent
j'entends encore hôtel officier de
renseignement du bataillon se vantait de
pratiquer l'étranglement progressif
jusqu'à ce qu'ils constatent que
l'individu entrée en érection
car paraît-il que lorsqu'on meurt par
pendaison avant de rire on a une
érection est donc à son man et de
relâcher et ils recommençaient et
jouissait avec ça lui
[Musique]
jma invités à venir pas pas assisté à la
torture par elle-même aux exactions mais
on m'a invité à rentrer dans la pièce le
mec est étendu par terre ils étaient
france pas qu'il soit mort mais elle est
torturée
le breton yvan le bolloc'h est affecté
au 31e régiment d'artillerie près de
sétif ce militant syndical qui a le
coeur à gauche s'attendait au pire en
arrivant d'algérie et saigne le sadisme
qu'il voit dépasser craintes les plus
noires
un autre au poste de police l'a par
contre même pas dans ce local au poste
de police où tous les appelés dormait et
s'apprêtait à les monter la garde là le
gars il était blessé grièvement et il
était allongé par terre à côté du poil
et
il y avait des
imbéciles qui rougit celle tisonnier qui
s'amuse à le piquer
il était là allongé sa djellaba c'est
pas qui c'était je sais pas
moi j'ai été élu porter un verre d'eau
mais bon ils étaient trop faibles et là
il ne pouvait pas accepter les
investissements vous parler c'est que
les appeler c'étaient les appeler parce
que bon grande majorité d'appeler
n'aurait jamais fait ça il y avait
toujours une poignée de gens aussi un
peu
malheureusement imbibé d'alcool et et se
permettait de faire ça
les blagues et
les exactions comme ça alors là je peux
vous en raconter
j'ai été étonné de voir que des copains
de village
pouvait avoir des comportements alors
qu'il pouvait être l'épicier du coin ou
des garçons gentils et tous des
comportements racistes sadique et
inexplicable mais ils étaient une
minorité mais ça existe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
oh
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je me souviens une autre fois par
exemple il y avait un prise quand on
rentrait encore doute d'une sortie il y
avait un prisonnier qui était allongé
d'un dans le patio il y avait un chien
là qui est en train de l'exciter et les
tortionnaires et quelques appelé était
autour et ça veut dire de beaucoup les
amuser
[Musique]
le racisme aussi parce que sa fonte font
parler
c'était quand même
ils étaient considérés comme des
sous-hommes c'était
c'était ça c'est ça qui m'a choqué quand
je suis arrivé j'ai bien vu là mais les
européens du village
pas tous il y en avait malgré tout
qu'ils ont toujours été sûr toujours
respecté les français musulmans il y en
avait mais par contre y en a vu d'autres
un jour une commerçante a proposé
un appelé peut ramener les oreilles de
fellaghas vont lui paierait l'apéritif
pensez bien
que le lendemain
le premier type qui se baladait en
sur une piste combien 3 km de celle où
il a été abattu c'était un
personnage et c'était un berger il avait
bu d'abord répondu assez vite aux
sommations
on va couper les oreilles
on l'a ramené les oreilles dans un
mouchoir
mon ami les oreilles sur le comptoir et
il a eu sa tournée l'apéritif j'ai vu ça
bien sûr j'ai vu les oreilles nous les a
fait voir
les oreilles dans un mouchoir oui c'est
ça ça ressemble plus à les oreilles
c'est houblon
[Musique]
le peut
m
[Musique]
où
e
oui
[Musique]
les copains me disais allez viens on va
au foyer on va boire un coup et puis on
va chanter ensemble tu vas tu vas nous
diriger un des morceaux et puis et puis
vous dire une chose on
s'amusait beaucoup parce que parce que
on n'avait pas envie de voir la guerre
on fait soir extraordinaire
surtout qu'en intégrant la musique art
et beaucoup de musiciens alors on chante
et on chante et enchante et pour ceux
pour oublier pour billets ça tellement
[Musique]
il y avait de fait 700 nous y avait
vraiment de face et en nous il fallait
bien parce que sinon on aurait crevé on
aurait crevé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fin de compte vous habituer
c'est facile de s'habituer des souffles
des souffrances d'autorité on avait bien
d'autres occupations donc la priorité
c'était de
sauver sa peau la priorité de l'heure
c'était deux
avec les copains
de tenir le coup jusqu'à la quille et on
devrait en apprendre à devenir cynique
[Musique]
mais en réalité même si on a
l'impression de s'habituer c'est
toujours un peu choquant je me souviens
une fois en sorte qu'on arrivait aussi
une sortie d'une patrouille ont traversé
le patio et il ya un hurlement
extraordinaire s'est jamais entendu ça
va après et avec les copains on s'est
arrêtés ont été figées on s'est regardé
un petit moment et puis on est reparti
dans notre chambre et c'était le grand
silence ou
sculptures ce qui est très très dur
c'est le renouvellement quotidien de ces
atrocités
jaillir sais
c'est pas jédir une douleur ou quelque
chose on peut arriver à s'accoutumer je
crois que ce type de choses on n'y
arrive pas à s'accoutumer
l'impression que la plaie elles augmenté
et se creuse de plus en plus que
ça devient de plus en plus de plus en
plus dur c'est
ça devient invivable soutenable
elle
n'avait pas l'impression que j'étais
tombé sur une bande un peu spécial que
cette villa susini les appliquer telle a
été quand même pas représentatif de
l'ensemble des appliques mais la guerre
d'algérie ce nom les gens qui étaient
dans la villa susini il n'était pas
excité le tout se faisait de sang-froid
calmement et ses activités quotidiennes
de la villa susini c'était quelque chose
de fait sciemment froidement
méthodiquement en fait c'étaient des
hommes enfin des jeunes hommes
ordinaires qui torturaient froidement
cette arrivée c'est arrivé à ce degré de
l'abjection effectivement je pense que
dans des conditions données je pense que
ça se fait peut être un peut pas faire
n'importe comment n'importe comment mais
je pense que dans un conditionnement
données d'un vin un moment donné ça peut
faire un pas par n'importe qui je crois
les apps était très conditionné pour
faire n'importe quoi et le
conditionnement ce qui va beaucoup
frappé c'est l'absence d'éthique
l'absence de retenue et ça j'ai pas
compris je ne comprends toujours pas
d'ailleurs mais c'est peut-être aussi
que au fond de l'être humain il ya une
espèce de bête le bâtiment ou si vous
voulez qui réfrénait par l'éducation par
effectivement
l'environnement par l'éducation
parentale mais placée dans un dans un
milieu aussi hostile
à l'algérien placés dans les consciences
ou si vous faites pas ça vous êtes le
lâchent des copains vous êtes le traître
ça m'est arrivé de faire traiter de
traître parce que j'avais refusé de
réanimer jeunes et à torturer les gens
se laissent aller ils ont passe comme on
dirait en psychanalyse ils ont passé sur
moi à cette défense pour résister à ça
les barrières tombent des barrières ton
tout des barrières tombent
peut-être que dans cinq cent mille ans
on commencera à voir ce que c'est qu'un
homme mais je sais que à l'heure
actuelle les la part animale ans l'homme
est encore très
très présente et la part d' animal en
l'homme moi je l'appelle le péché
jeu je suis persuadé que
tout seul pour résister pour se rebeller
en face de situations de ce genre
faut avoir des biens des qualités
exceptionnelles
ou alors avoir eu une éducation qui vous
prépare à vous opposer à un certain
nombre de choses comme ça alors je ne
sais pas est ce que c'est l'esprit
critique
est ce que c'est
la culture je ne crois pas que ce soit
la culture
je ne crois pas me souviens au petit
séminaire j'avais fait mes humanités
avait fait du grec et du latin j'avais
étudié tous les anciens j'avais bon la
bible et cetera bon ça ne concerne cette
culture ne constitue en rien un rempart
contre
des situations de ce jour bon la culture
non la religion pas apparemment enfin je
suis nul sans doute pas été un cas
particulier mais je pense que ça n'a pas
non plus été un rempart efficace
parce que bon parmi ces appelé je pense
il y avait une majorité qui avait eu de
formation religieuse une formation
chrétienne bon
alors quoi d'autre quoi d'autre au nom
de quoi enfin qu'est ce qui peut faire
qu'on s'oppose il faut chercher
peut-être au-delà du côté des valeurs
universelles
et puis se refusait à voir quelques
principes
auquel on tient en toute situation et ne
jamais dérogé à ses principes sinon
c'est le doigt dans l'engrenage et puis
on se laisse aller petit à petit à des
situations terribles
je sais pas je ne sais pas ça m'a rendu
peut-être plus
plus tolérant plus tolérant c'est assez
bizarre à dire bonjour quand je dis je
ça me semble aussi bizarre tu tolérants
vis-à-vis de gens qui se trouvent dans
une situation comme ça parce que je me
dis que n'importe qui mis dans ce type
de situation est capable de faire la
même chose n'importe qui
vraiment
sauf alors sauf à avoir une force de
caractère
exceptionnelle
j'ai plus en fait été convaincus que si
j'étais pas continuer à suivre le
mouvement j'étais condamné à
je ne sais quoi mais pas mais que je
n'allais pas m'en sortir indemne
totalement comme en plus il pour tenir
le coup finalement
je sais pas si j'ai résisté
vous avez résisté parce que vous êtes
resté
résister
aujourd'hui quand vous pensez à ça vous
dit que vous auriez pu faire autre chose
qu il était possible tu as quelque chose
donc la situation est tellement fermé
que nous étions confiants prisonniers de
cette situation
c'est même plus prisonnier sait
si ce n'est pas prisonnier ou cinq on
est dans une situation
est vraiment un katana nous puissions
[Applaudissements]
la guerre d'algérie n'en finit pas de
finir sur le terrain car nos français à
gagner politiquement le fln et vainqueur
désormais la population est acquise à la
cause de l'indépendance
de gaulle reconnaît l'algérie algérienne
qui se manifestent dans la rue lors de
ses voyages les négociations s'engagent
dans secret la paix est en vue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les desperados de l'algérie française
refuse la marche à la dépendance qui
semble inéluctable
challes salle rit jours dans un putsch
qui fait pschitt
[Musique]
soldats perdus et pieds-noirs désespéré
fond de l'eau as qui alimente une guerre
civile de plus en plus cruelles
[Musique]
certaines têtes brûlées prennent même le
maquis pour continuer le combat de
l'algérie française claude ranfaing
participent à cette aventure sans espoir
il est fait prisonnier par le fln
en étant dans l'embuscade là y'avait un
regroupement de la willaya cat de
plusieurs katiba qui nous sont tombées
dessus on a accroché il était 2h
2h30
j'étais prisonnier le soir
il va être 18 heures quand j'étais
prisonnier qui commençait donc c'était
des cours on était il nous avait attaché
dans la ferme là y avait moi j'étais
attaché après un anneau de commandes
attaché les gradins étaient attachés là
il nous a ému tout moi j'étais tout nous
devons les femmes déjà bon bah c'est ça
c'est un peu le principe pour faire
perdre un peu les moyens à quelqu'un
qu'on interroge bon alors c'est tel
matraquage après bon bon ils ont dit
mais on va vous montrer comment vivaient
les français commençaient que vous
faisiez
etc tu vois lui est passé il était pris
par les mains par les françaises qui lui
en fait tout bon ils m'ont mis à ils
sont amusés à mettre un fil à la verge
un autre à l'oreille
du coup on bombarde le
chat mais je sèche je savais et l'effet
que ça pouvait faire quoi bon bain après
bon après le matraquage après lyon n'a
qu' eelv ont dit bon on va te couper la
gorge et il était là il affectait le
couteau pour me [__] d'être oui bah on
y croyait vraiment un et vous pensiez à
quoi penser pendant que vous étiez
torture et
je vous dirais qu'il ya vous êtes dans
le brouillard vous êtes carrément dans
le brouillard vous prenez des coûts bon
au début ça fait mal il m'avait il
m'avait défense et les côtes
avec avec leur canne de leur canne de
montagne là j'avais bon j'avais tout le
dos et bray il a pris magie s'est elle
amusée d'ailleurs j'ai toujours des
traces sur la poitrine il s'était amusé
à me tailladé au couteau un peu la
poitrine bon je dis bon ben si je
souhaitais une chose je veux si je pense
est une chose c'était qui me tape à
coups sur la tête qui m'a somme avant de
me voir j'ai
parce que j'avais quand même je savais
qu'ils pratiquent l égorgement j'avais
quand même vu des photos que j'ai c'est
qu'il équipe qui pratiquaient qui est
masculin et tout ça donc j'ai dit
j'espère qu'ils vont pas nous faire
c'était à sa gare est qu'on m'avait le
plus peur quoi pour si vous étiez foutu
ah oui ah oui pour moi j'étais j'étais
foutu j'étais fou le site est quand même
une drôle de situation dans laquelle
vous étiez parce qu'en quelques mois
vous étiez passé de
tortionnaire a torturé quel effet ça
faisait je n'aime pas tellement le mot
thorson a quand même à ils vont enfin
vous subissiez ce que vous aviez fait
ouais si vous voulez
le 18 mars 1962 qui représentant de la
france et du fln parviennent à un accord
le cessez le feu est signé la guerre
civile continue
dans les grandes villes à oran et à
alger les commando de l'oas s'attaque à
l'armée française et eu des appelés du
contingent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le djebel le fln qui s'apprête à
s'emparer du pouvoir poursuit ces
exactions on relève des européens qui
disparaissent et exécuté a requis que le
gouvernement français lui abandonne
au cessez-le-feu ben
c'est pas trop quoi faire mais moi je
sais que je partirai pas au frais au
fond de moi
j'ai toujours rien un doute que je
voulais éclairé que frej
et inconsciemment mais mais très fort
sentiment très fort dans le fond je me
suis laissée
enlevé pour à peu près se dit pas si
pour expier serait trop fort
mais en fait j'étais content comme vous
m'arrêtez contrôle aujourd'hui de passer
de l'autre côté du miroir oui j'avais
j'avais envie j'avais besoin de ça
je signe maintenant je vous parle de ça
justement c'est parce que je suis passé
de l'autre côté aussi et j'ai vu la
différence j'ai vu ce que c'est donc ils
m'ont arrêté
en premier le 30 mai 62
et puis c'était le soir
puis tout de suite je suis arrivé autour
de moi ils m'ont mis les mains derrière
le dos attaché avec une fourragères
militaires sont de la récupération 1,60
à tuer
et moi avec ma montre j'avais un petit
peu d'argent dans le fonctionnement prix
lendemain et à d'autres qui sont venus
me chercher emmené dans une salle is
pour m'interroger alors là j'ai connu
une autre forme de torture on n'essaie
pas de d'obtenir un renseignement
mais c'est simplement de punir quelqu'un
de le faire de le faire mourir à petit
feu essayez-vous le jour il vous
torturer comment un scoubidou
c'était l'époque où on faisait des
petits scooby doo pour faire des
porte-clés ils ont fait une canne quoi
mes nerfs de bleu d'abord plusieurs
scooby doo et ensuite scooby doo de ce
que moscou lido savez un truc comme ça
exactement comme un air de ben alors les
coups ça faisait le tour du coran
à une épaule ça ça vous arrache la peau
c'est un peu le fouet un ça ça donne les
mêmes le même blessure 1 mais il y avait
doute roy qui était pressée qui
voulaient aller plus vite qu'ils avaient
des lames gillette qui voulait commencer
à me découper
et puis un acquis non non petit à petit
il faut pas aller trop vite on va
déjeuner d'avoir
et quand ils sont partis pour déjeuner
j'ai réussi à passer les mains devant et
enlever les liens plus j'ai attendu et
quand ils ont ouvert la porte je suis
entré dans une sortie comme une flèche
il y avait des barbelés mais qui est au
mauvais état ils ont piétiné un j'ai
sauté pour les barbelés et par chance je
me suis pris les pieds je suis parti à
plat ventre et pendant que j'étais par
terre une rafale de mitraillette
j'ai vu le sable enfin là la terre à
5-6 mètres de moi si je n'étais pas
tombé à ce moment là j'étais bon et puis
j'ai mis pratiquement toute la nuit pour
arriver à azazga j'étais à la brigade de
gendarmerie
ils me connaissent et ils n'ont pas
voulu ouvrir j'ai dû passer par dessus
le mur on risquait de me faire tuer par
aussi imaginer un peu et puis le
lendemain il m'a envoyé à l'infirmerie
militaire je suis resté cinq jours et
puis je suis venu en france
des milliers des dizaines de milliers de
harkis sont liquidés dans des conditions
atroces le fln veut effacer toute trace
des algériens qui ont choisi la france
je pensais que les accords d'evian était
pas respecté par contre j'ai eu des amis
qui ont
été maintenus là-bas en 62 et qui ont
assisté à un puissant aux scènes de
violence du fln par rapport aux harkis
ça a été
des choses qui aujourd'hui je considère
comme étant la honte de la france
[Musique]
mais mes copains harkis que j'avais avec
moi tous les jours et d'un seul coup je
les ai plus c'est je suis un orphelin de
cette famille des harkis je ne peux pas
je peux pas supporter
c'était dur c'était des hommes qui nous
avait fait confiance on leur a dit on
vous laissera jamais tomber et la
première chose qu'on a fait on leur a
tapé sur les doigts quand ils se
cramponnent ou rivel pour monter dans
les camions pour sauver leur peau
[Musique]
si vous été témoin de l'utilisation de
harkis dans cette période oui oui de 2
seulement donnent seulement voilà
comment ça s'est passé on leur a fait
boire de
l'alcool à brûler ils ont mis le feu
c'est au début oui ça les bruits et les
bus je voulais je donne de notre village
oui j'ai vu c'est pas très loin derrière
et là on a vu arriver les premiers
partis
dont un qui était qui était dans la même
dit oum que moi que j'ai vu est
interrogé ils ont
résonné bien sûr il était prisonnier ou
un mur où le malin lui c'était c'est
incroyable ce qui lui en fait est le cas
il n'a jamais parlé enfin moi c'était le
gars qui étaient avec moi le arctique
était avec avec moules
il était attaché il l'avait attachée
avec du fil de fer il ya des fils de fer
avec tous les coups ça a duré mais ça a
duré plus de trois semaines de de tout
ce qu'il a pu subir
même à nous on n'a jamais su sans nom il
nous a jamais dit sans nom il n'a jamais
dit où il habitait
puis on pouvait rien faire et ils
voulaient pas qu'on lui donne à manger
il y avait brisé les reins il se
traînait comme alors essayé de le porter
hurlait le pauvre type
il peut caler 35 ans type costaud
il en a bavé puis après les autres
balises ont fait ce qu'on appelle
hélicoptère
c'est à dire qu'il vous pente par les
pieds et par les bras et ils font du feu
de sous le ventre
ils vous font cuire comme un mouton mais
vivre en vue
oui je l' ai vu de mes yeux c'est
mathilde les achever je ne lâcherai à la
pioche
ah oui oui
parce qu'autrement jallet le lan terrain
il voulait que je n'enterre il était
encore vivant
mais bon j'en ai vu d'autres qui ont été
embarqués qui bon c'est parce qu'il
france avait on savait très bien ce
qu'ils on faisait mai mais bon ben j'ai
bien j'ai bien que pour eux bon bah
c'était
il avait trahi leurs frères quoi mais
nous pour nous nous français ben c'est
nous nous on les a trahis aussi
le 3 juillet 1962 l'indépendance de
l'algérie proclamer la ln entre dans
alger la page est tournée
il
[Musique]
oh
à
le couple
[Musique]
o
moi je
il
or
on a pleuré
on a pleuré quand il y avait la radio il
avait la radio des postes transistors là
bon c'était l'hymne national algérien
ce moment là on est montés ils ont
montré dans les camions et il descendait
sur les villes et en traversant un
village il y avait encore de l'armée
française on était les quatre
prisonniers dans le camion
il ya encore le drapeau il n'avait pas
encore descendu le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge et on s'est mis tous les cas toga
au garde à vous dans le dans le camion
et on va saluer le drapeau français
revenant pendant un an j'ai pas dormir
je suis revenu tout seul personne ne
l'attendait plus trash suis rentré chez
moi points
je suis aussi perdu à mon retour que je
le suis en arrivant en algérie
complètement sans repères désaxé je mets
au moins quatre ou cinq ans pour pouvoir
à nouveau prononcé le mot algérie que je
vais muret et
soustrait de mon vocabulaire pour ne
plus parler de ça et tourner une page
j'ai l'impression qu'on peut pas
transmettre pour en fait faire
comprendre dans son intégralité d'un
saint dans sa profondeur
l'abjection de ce qui existait on se
libère pas de l'épire un canton quand on
l'a vu je dire je vis avec bon
on ne peut parler des choses que
lorsqu'elles sont envisageables or pour
la plupart des français il n'était pas
envisageable que la france ait fait ça
donc ils ne voulaient pas entendre
et ne pouvait pas entendre et donc on ne
disait pas
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
mon
mais
[Musique]
à